>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: VIRGINIA SENATOR TIM
KAINE HAS A WARNING FOR VIRGINIA
VOTERS.
IF REPUBLICANS WIN ON TUESDAY
THEY WILL THROW AN EMERGENCY
BRAKE ON THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
THANKS FOR SPREADING THE WORD.
HE MADE THESE COMMENTS
CAMPAIGNING IN VIRGINIA FOR THE
INCUMBENT DEMOCRAT WHO IS ABOUT
TO LOSE HER SEAT TO MY NEXT
GUEST.
THAT DISTRICT IS NEAR AND DEAR
TO MY HEAR.
IT WAS LABELED AS LEANING
DEMOCRAT BUT THEN IT WAS
SWITCHED TO A TOSS UP.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> VOTERS IN THE SEVENTH
DISTRICT ARE 6 AND TIRED OF
ABIGAIL.
THEY KNOW HE IS A LIAR AND
HYPOCRITE.
DEMOCRATS AND INDEPENDENTS ARE
SUPPORTING OUR CANDIDACY.
>> Laura: ARE HISPANIC AND
YOUNG.
YOU WENT FROM BEING ON A MORE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT POSITION TO RUN
FOR THIS POSITION.
YOU ARE GETTING UNDER PEOPLE'S
SKIN.
WITH HISPANIC WOMEN, YOU KNOW
HOW TO RUFFLE THE FEATHERS.
THIS IS A CHARGE MSNBC MADE
AGAINST YOU.
>> SOME PEOPLE TO DEFEND THE
INSURRECTIONISTS AS MY OPPONENT
HAS OR MANDATE A NATIONAL
ABORTION BAN OR INSULT THE FBI
CALLING THEM DEEP STATE AND
CORRUPT.
>> Laura: THAT'S ABIGAIL GOING
AFTER YOU.
ANY REACTION?
>> THAT'S A DESPERATE WOMAN WHO
CAN'T RUN ON HER RECORD AND WILL
DO EVERYTHING TO DISTRACT THE
VOTERS FROM THAT FAILED RECORD.
SHE DOESN'T WANT THE VOTERS TON
SHE VOTED WITH JOE BIDEN AND
NANCY PELOSI 100% OF THE TIME.
SHE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR CRIME
CRIPPLING OUR COMMUNITIES.
VOTERS ARE FLOCKING TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTIES IN NUMBERS
LIKE WE HAVE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
>> Laura: IN THE SEVENTH
DISTRICT PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO BE
TOLD TO BUY AN ELECTRIC CAR.
YOU ARE DRIVERS.
THAT HAMMERED FAMILIES IN
VIRGINIA.
>> IT HAS.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE MAKING A TOUGH
DECISION TO GO TO THE GROCERY
STORE OR GET GAS TO GO TO WORK.
>> Laura: AN INTERESTING QUOTE
FROM AN ARTICLE IN THE ATLANTIC
TODAY.
JOE GARCIA SAID THAT THE HISTORY
ON THE SIDE OF DULL DEMOCRATS
DULLS --
YOUR THOUGHTS THAT DEMOCRATS
HAVE LOST THE HISPANICS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
BECAUSE THEY ONLY PANDER DURING
AN ELECTION.
HISPANIC VOTERS ARE SICK AND
TIRED OF WHAT HAS COME OUT OF
WASHINGTON.
THIS IS WHY WE HAVE THE
MOMENTUM.
>> Laura: